foreign
[Music]
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
Entry how goes it out there I am cold No
Air
space
[Applause]
[Music]
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
thank you
what is happening to me
[Music]
she's entangled our light-based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you no
foreign
[Music]
I would never choose to bring anybody
into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
[Music]
faster
I can't can you I got it
Captain Rambo
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello hello
[Applause]
[Music]
where's Captain Rambo
what the hell yeah
hi we're looking for Kamala Khan
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
again
again hi where's our daughter Wherever
You Are
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign